hi herzlich willkommen zum heutigen
video leute ich bin ich dachte jemand
neben mir ist kein geringer als echte
und er kämpft mit mir weiter die
schlacht gegen den youtube algorithmus
der meine videos nicht vernünftig teilen
will
trotzdem schüchtern großeltern zusammen
deswegen den algorithmus heute probieren
wir uns gegenseitig mit vom lachen zu
bringen
wir machen könnt ihr einen snapshot
versuche nicht zu lachen und jederzeit
ein snap vorbereiten der andere härtere
gesetze mit ihren kopfhörern laufen und
rico fata nicht mitbekommt und das
eigentlich schon der ganze spaß weil ihr
kennt das bestimmt wenn man sich mit
freunden snack hin und her steckt bis
zum lachen zu bringen
laut richtig gutes an machen vielleicht
geht ja mal gucken einfach augen zu und
packte dabei soll während das firma
fährt auch gut da hat sich das überlegen
ich habe mir den film kaka machen rückt
irgendwie lustig fehlt da ist die frage
entwickler natürlich auch endprodukt
eingeblendet wenn wir als lustiges
gemacht haben wo ich glaube ich mache
nie gedacht dass ich mich fg und spielen
rückwärts ab und probiert man acht mal
klingt mit bittet mich okay ich probiere
ich schweizer damit endlich verstehe ich
habe meine vorbereitet hat ein video
du konntest und cookies keine miene zu
verziehen
das nicht lachen
jährigen euro erreicht ich habe schon
gemerkt wie lippen spannung war auf
jeden fall und wird nicht mehr regiert
heute haben wir machen einfach sagen ich
will vielleicht kennen sie das feature
man kann ja nun mit dem update bei der
schere lachen verschwinden lassen ich
probiere einfach mal verschwinden zu
lassen
und wenn man ja noch ein paar speaker
aus dem rasierten foto quasi lastete
auch auf das wirken
[Musik]
es ist schön diese pikachu möglich waren
weil die jungen gegentreffer
du hast die gemeinde an geschenken
versuch nicht zu lachen
ich bin nicht nach viele change fallen
normalerweise würde ich nie machen
versuchen nichts zu lachen für ein witz
aber wenn ich dann
mit dem drücken und sich dort hat mir
verloren
du kannst mal in ein junges wertung
sogar aktiv man hin will
mai nicht wieder was mit dicker machen
wie kann man so richtig zu machen ich
möchte meinen namen ausschneiden sdk
verwenden und dann nochmal komplett
überdimensionierte mein gesicht wetten
mal die nase aufschneiden okay du schon
mal gut ja sowas nicht zu lachen
die sparten schafft wenn du meine nase
anschaut absoluten neuanfang zu machen
weil ihr schaltet diese herkommen und
welche kunden versucht mir nicht zu
machen
eine spannendes wirtschaft wenn du meine
nase anschaut
bei der mine la aufgeschnitten
das war also menschen die nach langen
kämpfen
gerettet kino kino gehen und
[Musik]
der mann liebt das ganz entspannt ja
durch im rektorat gemacht hat einfach
einen onlinestore post von der art her
recht ähnlich
du bist verklärt lachen kann man lieben
veranschlagen oder eine finalrunde auch
einbauen können sich halt erst einmal
überlegen
es gibt schönere auch was richtig gutes
[Musik]
eine idee war
ich bin mir danke ich euch das einbetten
wer weiß vielleicht würde bleiben
empfinden ist natürlich nicht gemeint
wir machen niemand wird aber keine
möglichkeit für wir sind nicht so dumm
um irgendwie zu glauben dass
irgendwelche bevölkerungsgruppen
schlechter als andere wir warten über
alles und macht auf jeden fall dazu acht
glaube ich eine million für die nummer
nämlich ein künstler gemacht so aus spaß
mit dem die werbung im hat und dessen
vita
die deutschen von denen millionen ihr
aber eine million verkehr zwar schon
bald muss man sagen dass ich mir einfach
am sommerberg leben gekommen
niedermatten könnten aktuell aktionäre
ein schweizer
heute leute da muss ich mal das video
hat euch gefallen war etwas andere idee
von mir vergeht leute die sich selbst
gegenüber wegen kälte abonniert nicht
doch und